bei uns ist jetzt unser chefreporter aus
der politik peter tiede denn am morgen
steht sie dann schon wieder an die
nächste mpk darüber müssen wir natürlich
reden droht uns dann doch schon der
frust vor weihnachten oder etwa nach
weihnachten pz jeder bei uns im studio
die schönen guten tag und er hat man es
jetzt ja doch eilig ganz schnell eine
mpk einzuberufen wo es ja also wir
hatten ja den wunsch aus den unions
ländern schon in der vorigen woche oder
auf jeden fall vor weihnachten noch eine
mpk zu haben da hat man sich geeinigt
dass man erst den expertenrat den neu
gegründeten 19-köpfigen expertenrat der
bundesregierung anhört dass die erste
stellungnahme abgeben das ist ja neu
bisher gab es immer bei der alt
kanzlerin merkel gab es immer
irgendwelche wissenschaftler mit denen
sie am wochenende telefoniert hat man
wusste nie genau von wem lässt sich
beraten jetzt gibt's ein transparentes
gremium 19 leute wissenschaftler aus
allen möglichen bereichen und aus
praktiker zum beispiel wie der landrat
aus parchim aus mecklenburg vorpommern
also wirklich breit breitgefächert und
die haben gestern abend ein papier
vorgelegt 33 seiten ich habe es hier
vorliegen und das hat es in sich weil
die haben geguckt was passiert uns jetzt
mit omikron und bisher haben wir immer
diese berühmten verdopplung traten also
wann verdoppeln sich die zahl der
infizierten die war bisher immer so bei
zehn zwölf tagen in der spitze jetzt
drohen uns verdopplung traten die etwas
langsamer sind bei omikron als in
großbritannien aber immerhin zwei bis
vier tage und das würde dazu führen dass
wir alleine durch tests und durch andere
jeden tag jeden zweiten tag eine
verdoppelte zahl haben also 200 400 800
also dem exponentiellen wachstum sind
und das würde heißen dass wir so viele
kranke haben dass die krankenhäuser
nicht mehr hinterherkommt es eine ganz
klare waren hier drin und vor allem
selbst die leute die nun quarantine
müssen die würden sich quasi stapeln
weil nicht mehr nach zehn tagen zwölf
tagen dann die verdopplung da sondern
der 234 tagen und dann werden wir quasi
nicht mehr genügend leute um das land zu
versorgen also hier steht es ein punkt
man hat sich 1919 also 19 wissenschaft
haben sich einstimmig auf dieses papier
geeinigt die bandbreite ist groß von
professoren drosten von der charité bis
hin zu bis hin zu henrik strikt also die
beiden haben sich immer diese position
sind eher die antipoden beide sind sich
hier eigentlich
gefährdungspotenzial für die kritische
infrastruktur
da wird jetzt traut darauf abgehoben
dass die telekommunikation
rettungsdienst strom- und
wasserversorgung krankenhäuser polizei
feuerwehr und die logistik gefährdet
sind dass man notfalls
für anfang januar erstellen muss falls
dieses worst case das ist das worst case
also der schlechteste fall der
schlimmste fall eintreten kann tritt das
ein sei die kritische infrastruktur in
deutschland gefährdet also die
versorgungssicherheit des landes das
müsste jetzt mit bundeswehr thw und mit
anderen plänen gesichert werden es gibt
es auch punkte zu kontakt beschränkungen
ja das ist das was konkret gefordert
wird ohne genau zu sagen wie auch das
ist übrigens neu dass die
wissenschaftler in der politik sagen was
die politik machen soll sondern nur
sagen die miss kontakt beschränkung
machen wie beschreiben euch eine einlage
entscheiden tut du dir und sie fordern
noch vor weihnachten also jetzt sofort
ab morgen kontakte beschränken wie die
aussehen könnte wissen wir noch nicht
genau das würde wahrscheinlich heißen
mit weniger leuten weihnachten feiern
sich kaum noch treffen kleinere gruppen
nur noch ein großveranstaltungen absagen
dass man eigentlich alle veranstaltungen
absagen müsste vielleicht sogar die
gottesdienste zu weihnachten ob die
wackeln das werden wir alles morgen
erfahren heute gibt es eine gibt's eine
schaltkonferenz der chefs der
staatskanzleien der länder und dem chef
des bundeskanzleramts und dann muss man
mal abwarten welche maßnahmen noch
direkt vor weihnachten kommen aber das
was hier gesagt und für den jahresanfang
also und wir werden vor dem januar
gewarnt die ersten januarwochen könnten
wirklich katastrophal wenn etwas das
noch nie gehabt haben und das liegt
daran nicht mehr um mikro und schwerere
fälle macht oder schwere verläufe macht
und einfach weil mehr leute in kürzerer
zeit krank werden und das könnte das
land an die belastungsgrenze führen im
schlimmsten fall
werden gesundheitsminister hier der hat
er gesagt jetzt vor weihnachten schließe
einen harten locker und erstmal aus das
ganze wird einfach verschoben auf nach
weihnachten in welcher form auch immer
na ja also wir haben die rechtliche
möglichkeit für diesen berühmten bundes
locker und die existiert nicht mehr und
auch die bundesländer können nicht
einfach einen lockt und verhängten was
möglich ist ist dass ich 16 länder
einigen dass sie mit dem ganzen
instrumentenkasten denen sie haben mit
unterschiedlichen maßen fiel quasi
aneinanderreihen kannst einen lock down
ähnlichen zustand herstellen können also
du kannst das land nicht komplett runter
fahren aber du kannst wenn sich 16
ministerpräsidenten einig sind und damit
in zum teil müssen doch in ihrem
parlament also das könnte spannend
werden wir werden in einigen
bundesländern jetzt nochmal
wahrscheinlich nochmal landtagssitzung
haben haben müssen weil die verordnung
erlassen müssen und die müssen dann noch
durch die landtage durch die sich
einigen vielleicht entdecken zweig
absage von veranstaltungen
beherbergungs verbot vielleicht sogar
wieder bestimmte sachen dann kann das
land in einen lockeren ähnlichen zustand
gehen und ziel ist zumindest von den
unionsländern so viel wir wissen und der
bundesgesundheitsminister das auch gerne
so eine art weihnachtsruhe also zwischen
weihnachten und neujahr das land quasi
in seiner art weihnachtsschlaf verlegen
dass ich die leute kaum bewegen das so
gut wie nicht bald passiert und bis in
ruhe zu bekommen und ich wage mal die
prognose es wird nicht bei einer
weihnachtsfeier bleiben wenn am nikon so
kommt wie es hier prognostiziert wird
dann haben wir einen harten januar vor
uns der entscheidende satz in dem papier
peter wenn ich das richtig zitiere ist
er wirksam bundesweit abgestimmte
gegenmaßnahmen zur kontrolle des
infektionsgeschehen sind vorzubereiten
insbesondere gut geplante und gut
kommunizierte kontakt beschränkungen ja
und das heißt halt gut kommuniziert den
leuten das erklären und das ist halt das
problem und man ist in einer
weihnachtszeit das ist ohnehin eine hoch
emotionale zeit dann kommt noch neuer
mittel dazu eigentlich ist man auf
familie und auf besinnlichkeit
eingestimmt und auf besuch sich
gegenseitig zu besuchen zusammen
silvester zu feiern und das kann
tatsächlich an den die hose gehen und
was sie da lesen also dieses bundesweit
abgestimmt heisst als 16 bundesländer
müssen sich einig sein weil es geht
nicht mehr zentral die zeiten wo per
ordre de mufti aus berlin meinen land
abgeschaltet wird die zeiten sind zum
glück vorbei
das muss jetzt alles andere wege gehen
und das ist nicht immer einfacher das
ist manchmal kompliziert aber ich glaube
das was wir gestern aus den
bundesländern gehört haben haben wir mit
mehreren staatskanzlei auch schon
telefoniert und da ist die bereits
relativ große relativ weit zu gehen
peter thiede mit einschätzungen zur
aktuellen corona situation hier in
deutschland kurz vor dem fest dass uns
auch weit bis über das fest hinaus
begleiten wird danke dir